[Music]
so how does it feel to be back part for
this second ant-man it's a treat I mean
first of all the best things about
sinkholes is that you already know the
people you're working with there's a
comfort factor I'm just going you know
go through the introductions and the
formalities again so Peyton Reed our
director very well and Paul Rudd
evangeline so it's nice it's a comfort
factor because it's a sequel that means
they wanted more yeah Cyrus makes it a
little more easier when you start the
film yeah
and we're just tremendous have you seen
if I don't have no I haven't seen it my
gosh it is my favorite movies ever
Wow yeah that's your I just wanna make
sure my favorite movies ever honestly it
was so funny here yeah we're getting
unbelievable response from the people
that are seeing it so the Monday night
we have them our premiere so I'm looking
forward to it yeah you should be and
they're gonna love it yeah I mean cool
points do you get for being a part of
this franchise cool points for me kids
but the kids who after the first one
yeah we had the premiere the first one
my son Dylan came to me and he was
probably 15 at the time and he's a
serious actor himself he's been working
at it for a while and he looked at me
very seriously she said dad I said yeah
this is good for your career I said this
this is gonna introduce you to a younger
audience a new audience I said thank you
said you should think about doing a
sequel so I said well thanks thanks -
I'll take the advice so good right there
very good advice so and he was right I
must say I kind of forgot about it and
then I've had more than once be talking
to somebody and feel something tugging
on my my jacket looking down and there's
some five-year-old always looking up and
man
[Laughter]
so now she knows who you are like yeah
some of your other movies you know big
guys right I'm sure you know this one
they can actually get it go see if you
know what it was I know what you're
saying yeah
was it fun you do some some fighting in
this one you decide you know yes um I
know most important I finally got to
wear the suit
yeah I was a little disappointed in the
first one and Paul Rudd looks so great
in masculine and muscular and all of
that so yeah finally got a chance to
super to to wear this suit and and and
and people think that I'm some kind of
scientific brilliant engineer by the
dialog that I have little do they know
hey yeah we were gonna kick got some
serious you know what I'm saying
yeah back in shape - you look really
good in shape thank you thank you trying
did Catherine say anything to you about
like looking look she just tries to keep
a straight face this is this is some of
your finest acting yeah that's good um
and I understand that your would be
willing to play the young hangs in a
ant-man prequel well I you know more
than more than I do
I write a little are just a young Hank I
must say well first of all let's talk
about as we struck the picture and I now
find out that we're gonna be introduced
to my my wife Chad that Michelle
Pfeiffer he's gonna be playing the role
how great that such a big fan of hers
and she's a wonderful actress and then
I'm reading is a layman Michelle
Pfeiffer and I are gonna be 30 years
younger this is too good to be true so
now I'm now mama mine's just reeling I
said I'm I got 50 plus films in my
career I think I should just start over
it you know yeah just do that so we have
some scenes in the picture where you get
to look 30 years younger which is which
is pretty weird not it was it fun in a
way too
well I mean when you say and when you
see it I've just seen one parts when I
was looping and buddy saw it from the
earlier the first ant-man's we did it
it's a little strange it's a it's a
little strange it's it's funny but just
sort of think about what the options are
I'm limited to what you can do right you
know then we're gonna start morphing you
know combinations the montgomery clift
with Spencer Tracy and you can tweak
these these Bionic characters well
that's a whole nother series right right
that would be fantastic
yeah well then they could make you like
they could have you do a prequel
sure well you have some younger version
of me yeah but they could do the digital
absolutely but I still thank you forever
young thank you yes yes it's true nobody
has a better hair than you either you're
giving me competition as you saw the
humor in the movie is off the charts and
amazing do you think that that's what
the fans needed after Avengers infinity
war well I think in the in the Marvel
Universe
they ain't smart me intelligently saw
that if you're gonna go small if the
idea of developing superheroes had Billy
Lee go small that there's an inherently
some humor possibilities with that and
then if you bring Paul Rudd into the mix
who constantly is a wonderful writer and
comes up with all of these amazing
ad-libs and quirks that that will add to
it and I hear I'm looking forward to
seeing that picture that ant-man and the
wasp is even funnier than the first one
and it seems to be a lot of that and I
think that would be the natural way to
go I don't know how much more action
thriller wise you can go with the Marvel
pictures of ask the Furious and this and
that until you bring in comedy yeah I
remember you going back years ago I did
a picture called Romancing the stone
which was was an action romance action
picture and
we try to have some comedy into a
tubular no you can't do that that's
impossible
and then ultimately it worked out just
fine yeah sure did that one worked out
quite well I say yeah you know um how
does it possible that you and Michelle
Pfeiffer have never worked together
before now I was like thinking about him
like that's it just doesn't seem
possible i I don't know I think Bush you
know I don't know where I've worked
pretty much all of her her other
actresses parts but you know just happen
so what was it like was it just well
she's great she's just she's a lady
she's professional she's intelligent
she's really good and we got at it you
know just quit Kelly you get at it and
you're just always happy when you got
somebody you're working with who's who's
good you know I produce a lot so I
probably more than most actors aware
making everything as as good as it can
be you know I'm not as as worried about
my part of my role as I am welcoming
making sure everybody else is good
because the most important thing is a
good movie the parts fall where they may
you know sometimes you got a great part
but you want to be in a you want to be
in a great movie yeah and your kids I
mean just as I could ask you a little
bit about them Dylan first of all they
grow up too fast don't they they grow up
too fast I mean first of all my my older
son Cameron he's an actor now he's out
here in in Los Angeles Cameron has just
made me a grandfather then Dylan yeah
Dylan is is graduated from high school
now he starts college next year and
caris is 15 and all of them all of them
three of them are all actors y'all want
to be actors and so I have no idea no
idea but I saw Kirk last night we had
dinner - yeah
and that kind of we were reminiscing and
I said look at you and I we got a
hundred and fifty movies together
spanning 80 years Wow and you have four
grandchildren because all sir Kelsey my
niece is Kelsey you have three guys and
a girl all want to be actors so I think
after 150 movies in 80 years
I see an easy 200 pictures in 150 years
you know sir so they're all good the old
the old name of Douglas to dad came up
with gonna be around for a while
they gotta continue yeah that family
business yeah are you okay you cool with
them going to the family business if
they're happy I'm happy you know it's as
long as they love acting that's the big
thing you can't just count on yourself
being a star but if you really loved
acting wanna do theater acting your
musicals community go forth then it's
okay it's absolutely all right
any advice lope getting into that
business well just get there scary parts
of it rejection rejections the toughest
part of acting is have to recognize and
know that rejection is he is a good part
of it and you can't get you know deeply
wounded every time it happens yeah
although yours is kind of worked out
pretty well
yeah I had my fair share of rejection
yeah I don't know yeah